[Música]
twiter suspendió permanentemente la
cuenta de donald trump quien tenía más
de 88 millones de seguidores después de
advertirles sobre sus incendiarios
mensajes analizamos en esta emisión
los demócratas de congresos siguen
presionando para iniciar procesos contra
donald trump tras el cauce del miércoles
que deja 5 muertos y decenas de
detenidos está previsto que la cámara de
representantes- se reúna para discutir
un proceso y enjuiciar al mandatario
saliente
el 2021 comienza de manera crítica para
américa latina donde las cifras de
muertes y contagios por kobe 19 están en
pleno ascenso brasil supera los 8
millones de casos y las 200.000 muertes
en colombia se registró más de 18.000
contagios en 24 horas y en perú salió un
caso de la nueva variante del
coronavirus
hola cómo están bienvenidos de vuelta
aquí a las noticias en france 24 mi
nombre es alan austria twitter suspendió
permanentemente la cuenta de donald
trump quien tenía más de 88 7 millones
de seguidores ahora a raíz del ataque al
capitolio la red social ha expulsado
previamente le había advertido a la
cuenta personal del presidente saliente
sumándose a las suspensiones indefinidas
de facebook e instagram esto después del
cauce del miércoles cuando seguidores de
roomba saltaron el capitolio en
washington al momento hay cuatro civiles
y un agente que intentó controlar a los
manifestantes muertos
enlazamos colores binner el analista
político y consultor internacional ex
diplomático estadounidense señor winner
gracias por esta comunicación en medio
de una cascada de dimisiones de la casa
blanca presiones para iniciar procesos
en su contra y ha callado en las redes
sociales
trump se está quedando solo hablemos
primero de las redes sociales señor
winner cómo leer la acción de twitter
plausible tardía o en contra incluso de
la libertad de expresión
bueno ese ha sido definitivamente un
evento tremendo para donald trump hay
que recordar que donald trump se inventó
el estilo de liderar un país por twitter
está suspendido él ha dependido de esta
acción y este mecanismo para motivar a
su base ahora va a ser mucho más
complicando ubicado aún siendo
pretendido eeuu hay preocupaciones sobre
libertad de expresión definitivamente yo
creo que el presidente de méxico lópez
obrador mencionó eso y hay que tener
cuidado aunque yo creo que las acciones
del presidente el miércoles mostró al
mundo el peligro de mantener el control
de este mecanismo de medios sociales
ahora hablemos del otro tema y es que
mientras los congresistas demócratas
señor gómez siguen buscando activar los
mecanismos disponibles en la
constitución para que donald trump a
abandone el poder esto a pesar de que el
mandatario cambió el tono de anoche
asegurando una transición tranquila el
20 de enero la líder demócrata en la
cámara de representantes nancy pelosi
advirtió que si el vicepresidente mike
pence no invoca la enmienda 25 que
permite retirar al presidente por
incapacidad el congreso tomará medidas y
activará el juicio político o poder para
destituirlo agregó además que habló con
un alto mando militar para pedirle que
evite que trump acceda a códigos
nucleares está previsto que la cámara de
representantes- realice una reunión para
discutir los próximos pasos en su
objetivo de enjuiciar al presidente
después del caos del miércoles cuando
seguidores de trump asaltaron el
capitolio señor winner prosperarán estos
procesos contra trump cómo terminará su
presidencia
yo creo que es poco probable que van a
poder sacar a donald trump en los
próximos 12 días yo creo que hay
informes que el vicepresidente ya ha
decidido que no va a apoyar atacar con
enmiendas número 25 en cuanto al vicio
político los demócratas tienen la cámara
de representantes y por un voto de
mayoría de ese cámara ellos pueden
empezar el juicio político pero para
secarlo requiere un juicio en el senado
y es destinado que va a funcionar como
el jurado y en el senado todavía los
republicanos tienen 300 votos
probablemente para evitar que los saquen
de la oficina
entre dentro de la campaña y la
administración que viene de paine y no
está muy entusiasmados con un juicio
tampoco porque porque el último juicio
demoró 20 días yo yo bailé y su equipo
quieren arrancar quieren poner donald
trump atrás y quieren empezar a gobernar
con su equipo que el senado está en
juicio durante todos estos días va a
demorar y va a tener impacto en la
capacidad de iovine de empezar su
gobierno rápido entonces yo creo que hay
buen probabilidad que la cámara va a
votar para un juicio político pero muy
poca probabilidad y lo vara por este
caso
muy bien pues muchas gracias por esta
comunicación los minerales analista
político y consultor internacional ex
diplomático estadounidense en medio de
esta búsqueda de mecanismos de algunos
sectores para que trump no pueda
regresar en cuatro años al poder surge
la pregunta sobre si el mandatario
podría concederse un perdón presidencial
para evitar ser procesado una vez deje
la oficina oval hasta este momento
ningún presidente de eeuu
perdonado a sí mismo veamos
la presidencia de donald trump ha estado
envuelta en escándalos y controversias
luego de década pero vamos a ir al
capitolio vamos a tratar de darles el
tipo de orgullo y audacia que necesitan
para recuperar nuestro país
la gran pregunta ahora es qué es lo
siguiente para el mandatario de 74 años
se perdonará a sí mismo en un caso de
uso del poder presidencial sin
precedentes en la historia de eeuu de
acuerdo a algunos medios de comunicación
estadounidenses antes del asalto al
capitolio del miércoles que él alentó
trampa había discutido la acción con
algunos de sus principales asesores y
esto no parece demasiado descabellado
trampa ha estado tanteando esta
posibilidad desde hace tiempo el
presidente saliente está también
preparando una lista de indultos
preventivos para sus familiares y
ayudantes este anuncio llegará el
próximo 19 de enero durante su último
día en el cargo hay algunos problemas
por los que trump puede ser judicial
izado entre ellos están sus impuestos
federales sobre la renta pagos a una
estrella de cine para adultos por su
silencio su potencial intervención en
las interferencias rusas durante la
campaña electoral de 2016 y de las
presiones sobre el secretario de estado
de georgia para anular el resultado de
las elecciones de 2020
jens voigt
sólo quiero encontrar 11.780 votos nada
más la constitución dice que el
presidente tiene poder para conceder
indultos y perdones por delitos contra
eeuu excepto en casos de impeachment sin
embargo de acuerdo a la opinión legal
del departamento de justicia desde 1974
el presidente no se puede perdonar a sí
mismo con esto en mente la auto
clemencia nunca ha sido puesta a prueba
en el sistema de justicia estadounidense
y a día de hoy sigue siendo una cuestión
de disputa legal con los otros temas
porque en américa latina países como
argentina o méxico siguen la línea de
otras naciones de la región ya
anunciaron restricciones para frenar el
avance de la pandemia nos lo cuenta juan
pupiales
son días de buen clima en la argentina
el verano se siente en estas playas pero
en medio de un panorama preocupante en
lo que a la pandemia se refiere en los
últimos días los contagios diarios se
han más que duplicado en el país para
afrontar esta situación este viernes el
gobierno central restringe la movilidad
en la noche según el número de casos
registrados en los últimos 14 días los
gobernadores y gobernadoras cuando estén
en con estos riesgos epidemiológicos
deben tomar medidas relacionadas a la
restricción de circulación oa la
restricción de actividades adaptadas
naturalmente a su realidad adaptadas
naturalmente a sus costumbres y a sus
horarios
mientras tanto ciudad de méxico cuenta
con una ocupación hospitalaria del 86
por ciento este día aquí estaba previsto
que el domingo terminará el cierre de
negocios no esenciales el gobierno
capitalino anunció que esta restricción
finalmente se extiende hasta el próximo
viernes en la ciudad a un muerto de
23.000 personas a causa del cob y 19 en
un territorio en donde en total la cifra
de fallecidos
es más de 131.000 paciente vamos todos
los tres hospitales hasta cuatro y a
veces hasta en tres caras a su casa
porque no encuentran un hospital y
acaban por decirnos habanera usando
asado misión y buscar una alternativa de
un médico que vayas al domicilio o algún
tratamiento del caso al igual que europa
américa latina tiene ahora la
preocupación añadida de la nueva
variante británica del cob it este
viernes perú confirmó la detección de la
rama en una persona de lima que no había
viajado al extranjero la nación inca se
une a otros países como chile o brasil
que también confirmaron la presencia de
esta variación y brasil un día después
de haber superado los 200.000 fallecidos
reveló esta placa a las afueras de río
de janeiro en honor a aquellos que se
llevó la pandemia este viernes el país
supera otro umbral más de 8 millones de
contagios
muchas gracias siguen france24
[Música]